redondea 1585 a la de escena más cercana
y déjame reescribir el número por aquí
abajo
1585 y el redondear lo a la decena más
cercana haría que nos enfocáramos en la
decena entonces en esta parte de nuestro
número 8 ocupa el lugar de las decenas y
si lo queremos redondear hacia arriba
sería hacia nuestro número déjame cambio
de color a nuestro número mil 590 mil
quinientos noventa pues el 8 estaría
redondeado hacia arriba y si lo
quisiéramos redondear hacia abajo sería
nuestro número 1580 y ahora que ya hemos
visto ejemplos en nuestros vídeos
anteriores si el dígito a la derecha del
8 es 5 o mayor que 5 lo vamos a
redondear hacia arriba en este ejemplo
definitivamente dicho dígito es mayor
bueno de hecho es 5 así que vamos a
redondear hacia arriba a nuestro número